[Music]
foreign
I think for our department what binds us
and what kind of creates our identity
and culture is principles of equity and
Justice the way we study the way we form
the department itself is grounded in
those principles and once you focus on
things like equity and Justice it's hard
not to make that a focus in every aspect
of what you do so we try to really imbue
those principles
in how we run the Departments how we
select speakers how we treat and
interact with stuff and students and the
community we are a culture who really
believes in student voice most of what
we do that I think is good has emanated
from students and students ideas we
really look at this department as shared
shared with the students our students
are part of every kind of major decision
that we make they're part of all our
search search committees and that's
purposeful again from a from a equity
and Justice perspective you know we're
all in our department come from
different disciplines different
approaches different backgrounds but we
all share this common interest on making
the word more just and equitable
foreign
[Music]
is in kind of this built environment how
do we change the environment for Better
Health this is an inclusive design class
where public health and architecture
students would work with an organization
that provides services for for unhoused
individuals and so we're going to work
with them to create a place with the
goal of it being inclusive and that
serves the needs and wants of the
community
[Music]
research has been cited in in Supreme
Court cases that were cited to improve
the rights and well-being of lgbtq
community
individuals Donya Keane's work she's
actually on the New Haven Housing
Commission she does work on housing and
health so can take her work that she
does and Implement that into actual
practice of of New Haven housing laws
and and policies we've had students
who've developed
apps for a homeless teens and youth
we've had students who've created ngos
that are having amazing impact in local
and Statewide settings and then we've
had students who are on Departments of
Health that are actually taking what
they've learned in class and really
using it to to improve the the policies
the local public health policies in
their in their areas
[Music]